the babysitter killer queen has finally
hit netflix and fans are finding the
sequel flick to be just as gory
hilarious and flat-out bonkers as the
first movie from 2017. what does it all
mean let's break it down
but be warned there are major spoilers
ahead killer queen takes place two years
following the events of the babysitter
after the fateful night when young cole
johnson
learned that his babysitter b was part
of a demonic cult lusting for his
innocent blood so they could perform a
satanic ritual
unfortunately things haven't been too
great for cole since that night all of
his classmates think that he's crazy his
ostensibly cool parents want to ship him
off to a psychiatric high school
and his best friend melanie the only one
who knows he's telling the truth about
the blood cult is dating a complete
meathead even cole's guidance
counselor is quick to dismiss him and
his issues i get it i get it you're a
weird little dude with a crush on a
murderous fictitious babysitter
freshman is hard for everybody to make
matters worse just as things start to
look up when melanie invites coal out
for a day of fun on the lake it all
takes a grim turn
not only are melanie and her friends in
on the cult but all of the chord members
who cole managed to dispatch in the
first movie max
sonia allison and john rejoined the
party after having spent the last two
years in limbo
only the timely arrival of the cool new
girl in school phoebe
saves cole skin and the two must team up
so they can survive until sunrise the
blood guts and laughs fly fast and
furious as the babysitter killer queen
barrels toward its shocking twist ending
at the film's climax the cult captures
phoebe
and melanie lores cole to the secluded
cove where the ritual is to take place
this involves mixing the blood of the
innocent meaning cold's blood with the
blood of the sacrifice
and chugging it down before they do
however cole's deadly babysitter
b who has only been seen in flashbacks
makes a surprise reappearance to oversee
the proceedings
cole is shocked to see her and even more
shocked to learn that phoebe knows b2
b was phoebe's childhood babysitter
while driving young phoebe to retrieve
her stuffed bunny
bee collided with the car phoebe's
parents were driving resulting in a
crash that killed them
after the cult members drink the blood
cocktail and start disintegrating into
ash it's revealed that beard been
manipulating events all along
in order to sabotage the cult she
explains that she was gambling on one
variable
that coal would no longer be a virgin at
the time of the ritual which would
render the blood offering impure
fortunately colin phoebe had earlier
hooked up or hiding out at phoebe's
parents old lakehouse the reason for
bee's reverse heel turn are twofold
first she reveals that her initial deal
with the devil wasn't to improve her own
life but to save phoebe's after the car
crash
if she could be saved
what would you give look at anything
the second reason for bee's about face
is that when cole told her he loved her
a couple years ago
it completely changed her then in order
to ensure that the culture's done for
good
bee takes a swig of the blood offering
herself evaporating into black smoke
cause that arrives just in time to get
an eyeful of the freaky scene that's
going down
what the [ __ ] was that
mr johnson is finally convinced that his
son isn't crazy
cold and phoebe are free to embark on a
relationship the cult is defeated and
everything is wrapped up with a bow on
top
right well maybe not in a sneaky
mid-credit scene it's revealed that the
ancient spell book those crazy cult kids
used for their ritual
is still laying on the beach damaged but
intact this means that if the wrong
person were to discover the book things
could get all blood culty again in a
hurry also
there's a matter of max's comment early
on in the film we finished this by
sunrise we have to go back down to limbo
for another two years before we can try
again
let's get our core cocktail on and
finish this this could conceivably mean
that he
alison john and sonja might return again
in two years
although the first time the ritual was
screwed up by cole killing them all not
by a tainted blood offering which may
alter or negate the two-year limbo
period
the ins and outs of demonic blood
sacrifices are a bit unclear
that considered the ending of the
babysitter killer queen definitely
leaves a door open for the babysitter
three
but will we get it all signs point to
maybe in an interview with scream
actor judah lewis who played cole shared
that there were only murmurs
whispers and ideas floating around about
a sequel while shooting the first film
but now he feels that there are many
different paths to go for a potential
third outing lewis went on to say
not only does cole's relationship with
his dad change but his relationship with
phoebe would also be a really
interesting thing to explore and see
where it goes
plus he's got to get through high school
and i'm sure like always there are
demons lurking just beyond the shadows
that are ready to strike at any moment
something tells us that cole's respite
from the blood-soaked carnage will be a
short one
probably around two years check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about movies on
netflix are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one